PROFESSOR: It's doubtful if
you really understand something
if you can explain
why it's true.
That's what proofs are
about in mathematics
and in computer science.
So we're going to be talking
about proofs of lots of things
that we're trying to understand.
And in particular,
we're going to look
at a proof technique now called
proof by contradiction, which
is probably so
familiar that you never
noticed you were using it.
And now we're going to call
explicit attention to it,
and think about it.
So let's do an example first
to see what's going on.
Suppose that I wanted to prove
that the cube root of 1,332
was less than or equal to 11.
Or more precisely,
suppose I didn't know
and I'm asking this question,
is the cube root of 1,332
less than or equal to 11?
Well, one way to do it
would be to simply compute
the cube root of 1,332, which is
a small bother, but manageable.
But there's a simpler
way than figuring out
how to compute a cube root
of a four-digit number.
Let's just suppose
that this inequality
was true-- that is, that
the cube root of 1,332
was less than or equal to 11.
Well, if that was true,
then what I could do
is cube both sides.
And I'll conclude that 1,332 is
less than or equal to 11 cubed.
Now, 11 cubed is a
lot easier to compute
than the cube root of 1,332.
As a matter of fact,
11 cubed is 1,331.
Wait a minute,
I've just concluded
that 1,332 is less than 1,331.
That's obviously not
true, which means
that my assumption that
this inequality held
doesn't make sense.
It leads to this
immediate contradiction,
which means that in fact,
the inequality doesn't hold.
And I have now precisely
and unambiguously-- I
hope clearly-- proved that
the cube root of 1,332
is greater than 11, even though
we never actually computed
the cube root of 1,332.
This is kind of a [? toy ?]
and simple-minded example
to illustrate proof
by contradiction.
So let's step back and explain,
and say what it is in general.
If an assertion implies
something false,
then the assertion
itself must be false.
That's what's going on here.
If you're reasoning step
by step, and at every step
your reasoning is good-- which
means that if you had something
true and then you reached a
conclusion from it in one step,
the conclusion that you reached
was also true-- then if you
start off with some
assumption, you
keep proving things step by step
in a way that preserves truth,
and you arrive at
something false,
it's inevitable that
what you started with
must have been false.
Or else the thing you finished
with would have been true.
OK, let's look at a
real example of this--
an amazing fact that was
known thousands of years
ago to the ancient Greeks, which
is that the square root of 2
is irrational.
Now, let's remember that a
rational number is a fraction.
A rational number is a
quotient of integers.
And the way we're going to
prove that the square root of 2
is not a quotient of integers
is by assuming that it was.
So let's assume that
the square root of 2
was a rational number,
which means that we've
got integers n and d without
common prime factors, such
that the square root of
2 is equal to n over d.
What I'm doing here is
I'm saying squared of 2
as a fraction, n over d.
And we know that you can
always reduce a fraction
to lowest terms,
which means there
are no common prime factors.
So let's get that done.
We have the square root
of 2 is equal to n over
d, with no prime that
divides both n and d.
From this assumption,
I'm going to prove to you
that both n and d are even.
And that, of course, is an
immediate contradiction,
because then both n and d
have the common factor 2.
So all I've got to do
in order to conclude
that the square root of 2 is
an irrational number-- it's not
a fraction-- is prove to
you that n and d are both
even if the square root
of 2 is equal to n over d.
Let's do that.
We'll start off with what I'm
assuming-- square root of 2
is n over d.
And let's get rid
of the denominator.
So let's multiply
through both sides by d,
and get that the square root
of 2 times d is equal to n.
Let's get rid of
the square root of 2
now by squaring both sides.
And I get 2d squared
is n squared.
Well, that's great, because
look-- the left-hand side is
divisible by 2.
There it is.
Which means that n
squared is divisible by 2.
The right-hand side is even.
But if n squared is even, then n
is even, and I'm halfway there.
I've shown that the
numerator is even.
OK, let's keep going.
Now, since n is even, it's
equal to twice something.
So n is 2k for some number k.
I don't care what k is.
Let's square both sides of that,
and conclude that n squared
is equal to 4k squared.
Why did I square it?
So that I could connect up
here with the other question
that I had about it
n squared-- that n
squared it was 2d squared.
So combining these
two, what I get
is that 2d squared is
equal to 4k squared.
And of course, I can
cancel 2, and get that d
squared is equal to 2k squared.
And again, I've got the
right-hand side divisible by 2.
So the left-hand side
is divisible by 2.
d squared is even, and
therefore, d is even.
And we've completed
the proof as claimed.
n and d both have 2
as a common factor,
contradicting the fact
that their in lowest terms.
Now, I did assume something that
is kind of obvious-- namely,
that if n squared is
even, then n is even.
Why is this true?
Well, you might think
about it for a moment.
There's a simple way
to see it, and it's
a proof by contradiction.
We're going to use the fact
that you can verify easily
enough by doing a little
arithmetic-- namely,
the product of two
odd numbers is odd.
Let's assume that.
So if the product of
two numbers is odd,
if I tell you that
n squared is even,
and suppose that n was not
even, well, that means it's odd.
But that would mean that n
squared was odd, contradicting
the fact that n is even.
Therefore, it's a contradiction
to assume that n is odd.
It must be even
That's an ad hoc
proof that has to do
with evenness and oddness.
There's a more general way to
understand this that actually
will come in handy--
namely, that what I know
is that numbers factor into
primes in a unique way.
So if I tell you that
n squared is even,
what I know about n squared
is that all the primes that
divide n squared come from n.
So if there's a 2 among the
primes that divide n squared,
it has to be a 2 that is one
of the prime divisors of n.
And that would work
even if I told you
that n squared was
divisible by 3.
It would follow
by that reasoning
that n is divisible by 3.
Now, that's a powerful fact.
I'm assuming the prime
factorization of integers.
And it's not obvious at
all that that's true,
although it's very familiar.
It's OK to assume.
In a few weeks we'll
actually look back
at how to carefully prove that.
But for now, it's OK to assume.
And we also have
the simple argument
that worked based on
properties of even and odd--
that if n squared is
even, then n is even.
That's the last gap in the
proof, and so we're done.